-Our next guests are nominated
for two Grammys,
including Best New Artist.
Performing "TWO SHRiMPS,"
featuring Mac DeMarco,
please welcome DOMi and JD BECK.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Soft music plays ]
♪♪
-♪ Two shrimp pulled up my way ♪
♪ Like he'd never known ♪
♪♪
♪ Spare me where you came from ♪
♪ Grab the keys and go ♪
♪♪
♪ Cowboy out on the front lawn ♪
♪ Cowboy sun ♪
♪♪
♪ Eyeballs out
for the first dawn ♪
♪♪
♪ First dawn ♪
♪ The old man
sings a young song ♪
♪♪
♪ Young man's song ♪
♪ Here for now, but soon gone ♪
♪♪
♪ Two shrimp seated clearly ♪
♪ I must be gettin' old ♪
♪♪
♪ Sparin' where I came from ♪
♪ Cowboy out on the front lawn ♪
♪ And the cowboy's gone ♪
♪♪
♪ Eyeballs closed
for the big yawn ♪
♪ Big yawn ♪
♪♪
♪ The old man sings
a young song ♪
♪♪
♪ Youngest song ♪
♪ Goodnight kiss and so long ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Two shrimp pulling my hair ♪
♪♪
♪ And now it's time to go ♪
Okay!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]